iran is israel's best friend and we do
not intend to change our position in
relation to tehran
believe it or not this is a quote from
an israeli prime minister
but it's not ben gurion or golamayer
from the era of the shah
it's actually from attack rabbin
the year is 1987.
ayatollah khomeini is still alive and
much like ahmadinejad today he's using
the worst rhetoric against israel yet
rabin referred to iran as a geostrategic
friend
today when we hear the threats of war
and the high rhetoric we're oftentimes
led to believe that this is yet another
one of those unsolvable middle eastern
conflicts
with roots as old as the region itself
nothing
could be further from the truth
and i hope today to show you why that is
the relations between the iranian and
the jewish people throughout history has
actually been quite positive
starting in 539 bc
when king cyrus the great of persia
liberated the jewish people from the
babylonian captivity
a third of the jewish population stayed
in babylonia they're today's iraqi jews
a third
migrated to persia
they're today's iranian jews still
25 000 of them living in iran making
them the largest jewish community in the
middle east outside of israel itself
and the third return to historic
palestine did the second rebuilding of
the temple in jerusalem
financed incidentally
by persian tax money
but even in modern times
relations have been close at times
rabin's statement was a reflection of
decades of security and intelligence
collaboration between the two which in
turn
was born at a perception of common
threats
both states feared the soviet union and
strong arab states such as egypt and
iraq
and in addition
the israeli doctrine of the periphery
the idea that israel's security was best
achieved by creating alliances
with the non-arab states in the
periphery of the region
in order to balance the arab states
in its vicinity
now
from the shah's perspective though he
wanted to keep this as secret as
possible
um so when it comes for instance
traveled to iran in the 70s he usually
wore a wig
so that no one would recognize him
the iranians built a special tarmac at
the airport in tehran far away from the
central terminal so that no one would
notice the large number of israeli
planes shuttling between tel aviv and
tehran
now did all of this end with the islamic
revolution in 1979
in spite of the very clear anti-israeli
ideology of the new regime
the geopolitical logic for their
collaboration
lived on
because they still had common threats
and when iraq invaded iran in 1980
israel feared an iraqi victory and
actively helped iran by selling it arms
and providing it with spare parts for
iran's american weaponry
at a moment when iran was very
vulnerable
because of an american arms embargo that
israel was more than happy to violate
in fact
back in the 1980s it was israel that
lobbied washington
not to talk to iran
to sell arms to iran
and not pay attention to iran's
anti-israeli ideology
and this of course climaxed in the
iran-contra scandal of the 1980s
but with the end of the cold war
came also the end of the israeli-iranian
cold piece
suddenly the two common threats that had
pushed him closer together through out
decades more or less evaporated
the soviet union collapsed
iraq was defeated and a new environment
was created in the region in which both
of them felt more secure
but they were also now left unchecked
without iraq balancing iran
iran could now become a threat some in
israel argued
in fact the current dynamic that you see
between iran and israel
has its roots more so
in the geopolitical reconfiguration of
the region after the cold war than in
the events of 1979
because at this point iran and israel
emerge as two of the most powerful
states in the region
and rather than viewing each other as
potential security partners they
increasingly came to view each other as
rivals
and competitors
so israel who in the 1980s lobbied for
and improved u.s iran relations
now feared a u.s iran rapprochement
thinking that it would come at israel's
security interest expense
and instead sought to put iran in
increased isolation
ironically
this was happening at a time when iran
was more interested in peacemaking with
washington
than to see to israel's destruction
iran had put itself in isolation because
of its radicalism
and after having helped the united
states indirectly in the war against
iraq in 1991 the iranians were hoping
that they would be
rewarded by being included
in the post-war security architecture of
the region
but washington chose to ignore
iran's outreach as it would a decade
later in afghanistan and instead moved
to intensify iran's isolation and it is
at this point around 1993-94
that iran begins to translate
its anti-israeli ideology into
operational policy
the iranians believed that whatever they
did even if they moderated their
policies the u.s would continue to seek
iran's isolation and the only way
iran could compel washington to change
its position was by imposing a cost on
the u.s
if it didn't
the easiest target
was the peace process
and now the iranian ideological bark was
to be accompanied by a non-conventional
fight
and iran began supporting extensively
palestinian islamist groups that he had
previously had shunned
in some ways this sounds paradoxical
but according to modern indic
of the clinton administration the
iranians had not gotten it entirely
wrong
because the more peace there would be
between israel and palestine the us
believed the more iran would get
isolated the more iran got isolated the
more peace there would be so according
to indic and these are his words the
iranians had an interest to do us in on
the peace process
in order to defeat our policy of
containment
to defeat our policy of containment not
about ideology
but throughout even the worst times of
their entanglement
all sides have reached out to each other
netanyahu when he got elected in 1996
reached out to the iranians to see if
there was any ways that the doctrine of
the periphery could be resurrected
tehran was not interested
a few years later
the iranians send a comprehensive
negotiation proposal to the bush
administration a proposal that
revealed that there was some potential
of getting iran and israel back on terms
again
the bush administration did not even
respond
all sides have never missed an
opportunity to miss an opportunity
but this
is not
an ancient conflict
this is not even an ideological conflict
the ebbs and flows
of hostility have not shifted with
ideological zeal
but rather with changes in the
geopolitical landscape when iran and
israel's security imperatives dictated
collaboration they did so in spite of
lethal ideological opposition to each
other
when iran's ideological impulses
collided with a strategic interest
the strategic interests always prevailed
this is good news
because it means that neither war nor
enmity
is a foregone conclusion
but some want war
some believe or say that it's 1938
iran is germany
and ahmadinejad is hitler
if we accept this to be true that indeed
it is 1938
iran is germany ahmadinejad is hitler
then the question we have to ask
ourselves is who wishes to play the role
of neville chamberlain
who will risk peace
this is an analogy that is deliberately
aimed at eliminating diplomacy
and when you eliminate diplomacy
you make war inevitable
in an ideological conflict there can be
no truth no draw no compromise
only victory or defeat
but rather than making war inevitable by
viewing this as ideological
we would be wise to seek ways to make
peace possible
iran and israel's conflict is a new
phenomenon
only a few decades old in a history of
2500 years
and precisely because its roots are
geopolitical
it means that solutions can be found
compromises can be struck
however difficult it yet may be
after all
it was the sacrament himself who said
you don't make peace with your friends
you make it with your enemies
thank you
[Music]